[Music]
hey Bill I'm just curious what would
life look like if it had evolved from
viruses instead of bacteria
maybe life did evolved from viruses and
we just don't know it do to to to do to
to to however it sure looks like
bacteria went off on their own and you
know when I talking some more about me
in my book undeniable which I like to
think of as a primer a primer on
evolution I speculated that viruses
should have their own domain of life the
veera which in latin would be a second
declension noun in latin apparently they
did not have a plural of virus they
never needed one they never used it in
the way we use it today so I I don't
know if life evolved from viruses but in
my own experience I am thoroughly
charmed by the science fiction story
Andromeda Strain
where the compartmentalization of the
chemicals needed for life was done with
crystals rather than with membranes and
it's science fiction everybody but
bacteria are different from viruses in
that bacteria have these separate
structures whereas viruses seem to be a
single molecule what you might think of
as a single molecule and so viruses are
more akin to proteins than they are to
bacteria but proteins are created by
bacteria so it is very reasonable that
there was some ancestor to viruses and
bacteria so that they have in common the
common chemical ancestor proving that
seems to me it should be possible when I
was growing up people celebrated and
questioned and thought hard about the
Miller array experiment or array miller
experiment done by these two scientists
who tried to create the conditions of
the primordial earth
in a big glass flask and apparently the
one thing they didn't all the way
figured out was sulfur which now people
generally believe would have come into
the Earth's atmosphere from volcanoes
when I was in school at Cornell
University I walked into the Space
Sciences Building when Carl Sagan was
very active and teaching classes and
stuff and they had the early Miller
experiment running there's a big glass
flask with these electrodes sparking
because it was presumed or it is
presumed that in the ancient atmosphere
there was lightning and this electricity
could cause chemical changes that would
happen very very fast and so the idea is
that you would look for or try to create
molecules that through their natural
existence created copies of themselves
and so that was the goal it turns out
that creating amino acids these are
biological molecules that have a carbon
with a double bond and an oxygen on the
side that turns out amino acids aren't
apparently that hard to create and we
find them in asteroids and we find them
all over the earth and scientists or
chemists have been able to create amino
acids that have the same pattern but
don't exist in nature or we haven't
found them in living systems instead
they're very similar but they're not
that we don't find them in nature so all
this makes me think that it is
reasonable that someone could create
something akin to these primordial
atmosphere primordial conditions on
earth experiments that would make
molecules that replicated themselves and
we would find that the maybe there is a
common ancestor to both viruses and
bacteria whoa would that molecule be
dangerous would it be like a super virus
or the super bacterium and intuitively I
don't think so because we're all here
we know whatever happened happened and
it didn't kill us so maybe you'll be the
guy that figures out the early early
Miller in the next step the next step of
early Miller the next step of self
replicating molecules with primordial
components it is a very compelling idea
keep us posted
[Music]